might be really appropriate for MBA
[Applause]
today
there's never been done
[Applause]
well I would think was his body type I
would kind of look at him I don't think
he's like Doyle and be nothing good
he plays like a two-yard you know
[Applause]
Reba's only expect this from claim but
he was closely guarded by Jackson so we
went by him a little bit of contact
there but the officials are letting and
the players decide who wins what a play
by klay Thompson the presence of mind to
stay with it and shoot it without coming
down
look her raising up for the way
but he already did at the matter you
can't guard him one-on-one Booker is
crafty skill block the runner
it was his left hand he had to go a long
way
[Applause]
94 feet later back door keeps on going
in order to the full quarter final
seconds winding down holiday loses it
anime has a Booker releases it just
behind half-court time for Devin Booker
[Applause]
around on the three-point zone Fulton
homes donates $100 to son's charities
buckets for a deep Giants also selected
last year this is a lot of talent it's
so young
play time to the hot hand early on it's
his port he'll go already
Booker on the attack watches his shot as
he goes tumbling over the top of the
cameraman he just knows how to get it
off and then Devon just like and I just
got to get a shot off I'm not gonna loud
it Thompson one leg shooting continues
he had 19 points getting a double-digit
lead on LeBron and the Lakers
[Music]
yeah it's land that's good
all the highlight for chosen so take it
again get some of that he just grants
his right ankle on that dribble move by
clay and but you've got to taped in the
back we'll be back top said it is his
clothes mine he's sure he's showing that
he can do more than just spot up his
three-point shooting has been off the
mark to last several games and butcher
lost a handle that somehow manages to
get it dribble between the luego that's
gonna Pella beating those fouls win on
the perimeter
look at that move out though and he said
I'm gonna give it to you but hit it off
your arm and then your legs of that and
of course Carmelo Anthony's not with
this TV
[Applause]
[Music]
three doing what he does best it deep
straightaway look from Devin Booker
unable to knock it down this egg would
they did up and down yep John pocket two
very just shot
use the phone 24 these a Booker's
Thompson gets its chute still looking
for that three-point stroke
Booker's cashing in straight away over
the top at draymond Green or the season
from three you'll get an opportunity to
at least make them have to finish this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when feet set
[Applause]
it's not a shot that a caiman trail
Philadelphia to 23 turnovers leading to
29 points defense right now stifling
Booker off-balance - guys that's you
proud to own the three-point zone go
here in the third clock run it down
good basketball plays but they haven't
gotten the bucket on either one
[Applause]
deflected again another step to our more
it's kd-
capital taking itself
Enza ran off the good defense
chosen out [ __ ] Donnell said I'll give
it up to you
hooker gets the switch with Mac Mac's
dig up hooker raising up
and back to this set but your offense
against Devin Booker not good enough
[Applause]
and took it away pushing that play
after Kyrie Irving open it up with a 3/8
roll to the basket
and slams it down
I got a dinner way final four seconds
grandmas deep kick-out to play his three
when the Boston Garden crowd talked to
tearfully
now that Sammy came in and speaking of
cheering for Devin Booker the hometown
fans will as he knocks down the triple
Big D Aaron Cox a jumper absolutely make
him a jump shooter all the way to the
hoop here and clay hammering that before
be elites that could get their play has
a little edge there but 3-point field
goals made for game and his attempts
Booker on the deep release and Booker
knocks it down and beat his first Devin
Booker looking off that pick and defense
[Applause]
a quick smile
you had it assessed perfectly Jim
Jackson trying to work against Butler to
Butler one of the terrific defenders in
the league is he kicks it off the Devin
Booker and Booker with a high arching
rainbow he would shoot when he first
came here he was kind of turned sideways
and now he's kind of straightened out
Booker will look for the four-point play
a Devin Booker just he's really used his
screens well tonight and a great
follow-through
taffie scored one point but he was plus
26 the best of any player and a cycle
it's a loonie for the dunk he's got nine
now Booker on the drive gets it up off
the glass
and he will look for the and-one
that's the by the way but what you like
about Devin Booker coming down it's two
of the highest scoring teams in the NBA
awesome beautiful right and the foul on
a gorgeous bounce pass from draymond
Green offense
this is excellent execution just off of
eye contact trigger the inbounds they
get it to Booker Booker off the screen
[Music]
[Applause]
you know me it's just hard to be patient
guys guard saw the Rockets knock down an
NBA best 26 three-point shots catch and
shoot three coming from Melton that down
and goes proud to hold in greenpoint old
aggressive and assertive and especially
in the picnic oil situation
[Applause]
let's say that was a great defensive
possession for Utah
[Music]
[Applause]
Rondon
[Applause]
[Music]
are we looking for your cash finds a
shot clock
ball picked up three the shoot and
contesting good block as the Thunder get
a little loose with the basketball and
Josh Jackson nearly threw it away
hooker there for the save and Booker
said yes by OKC it's right now down a
33% Georgia just 5 of 15 Thompson with
the slam just great movement without the
ball by Thompson tall he's number one
picking the dress yeah I'm truly did
back problems areas up and rocks the rim
problem is you give up a 22 to run you
start getting behind by so much that the
back end of it back to that comet energy
do you have an a four-point play
opportunity might be a nice weighted
climb back perfectly time that ball
comes to meet clay Thompson right when
he's planning that foot and both of them
for him as he goes straight up suddenly
the biggest lead
Epic's smothers the shot up ahead to
Parker
slams it down on the right hand
excellent
back foot was there on the face line
[Applause]
pulls up short chocolate later dollar
paddles and the shot clock reset the 14
play Thompson tries again cats again
klay Thompson six for six
[Applause]
Booker steps in gets the steal
and I go down but the two-hand slam
there ant pull-up jumpers movie
offensive rebound Thompson what's in it
in clay Thompson sizzling merely opening
parody seven four seven five seconds
hooker head down got to get something
going Joe hooker cashes it in the sons
desperately trying to bring this losing
streak to one in draymond Green is
playing with a soul
[Applause]
I thought Boston was physical with them
the other night that's how you beat this
to cope their challenge doesn't matter
is Iguodala got a hand in there and
Brooke are able to raise up and connect
Thompson drives on Tucker better chance
in transition to create quality shots
Thompson got to let it fly late bender
with the offensive rebound and Hannigan
hooked up as Booker delivers at the horn
from deep Talking Stick resort
Booker the bullseye right on above the
five thousand leads in past a cappella
not close to peck talk like curry
Thompson the egg Adama for the slam but
Spaulding has five pounds inside raising
look at that block there from Devon book
that is HUGE right there but look at
this I mean he ran into a wall
[Applause]
steal by Kevin I had to Thompson Enda
hug another one
[Applause]
shot clock winding down now
butcher happened to take a one-leg
runner over the top of Drummond and
pellington and Drummond just kind of
laughs about that one after this one
here is a surface film is curry and
Tucker on him shot clock at five rivers
starting to rant so tough green don't
even more well it's one of the things
that that Dave Yeager talked about in
reference to his team but it certainly
applies here with these sons as hooker
Devin Booker off to a roaring start here
once the answer the challenge the buddy
hill runs them over hurried left-handed
high off the glass won't go amigo grabs
another rebound that's for Thompson of
Steel and the lamp whether it's the
change of address or just a role to play
much better and hit Booker to shoot
Thompson has Turner on him Thompson on
the drive shot clock winding down just
gets it off in time and backs at home
Jesus responds afterwards he was able to
have some fun in hooker wining this one
[Applause]
play against a lot of great school not
mean great schools obviously Michael
Jordan's obvious Steph Curry against
Turner lost it
picked up by Turner Turner goes Anna
Lane running left blocked by Thompson
water recovery from klay Thompson really
seeing incredible heart this is a team
would underrated hawk
underrated toughness underrated
competitive spirit in a year that's the
value of him and that's why he's one of
the best scorers in his league because
he scores on the perimeter anywhere on
the floor and then the meal but cool the
matter how big you are that he holds off
Bryant and then he just runs green right
out the picture I mean people don't
understand how strong he is and he's
gonna get stronger he's only 22 years
old what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content